to go all right well welcome everybody
thank you
so so much for joining us today um
today we are going to be talking about
networking
for referrals so a lot of you
um maybe in the position where you're
currently job searching you're looking
for a way to
apply the skills that you've learned in
your nanodegree program
and you know one of the best ways to get
hired these days is through the
through referrals and it's by far the
top strategy
for landing interviews as well as
securing
the jobs that you're applying for so
uh yeah let's go ahead and jump right in
um
with a brief kind of overview of who i
am so introduction
so uh my name is brett ellis i am a
career coach
with udacity um i've been here since
april
of last year so right around a year and
a half but most of my work primarily
most of my career i've spent career
coaching
whether it's through k-12 or higher
education helping young people
figure out what it is that they wanted
to do and then helping them get there
beyond kind of that experience i've
transitioned to start working with
other professionals leaders as well as
kind of narrowing my focus to it
professionals
when you talk to different career
coaches and some of you may have had
sessions with either me
or any of the other coaches you'll
you'll come to realize that people have
their areas of expertise
and for me i would consider those areas
to be personal branding
showcasing your impact and achievements
in in your work experience
as well as building your presence on
linkedin and so a lot of the things that
we'll be talking about today
will fall into those categories um and
yeah i think
out of all the things that i enjoy doing
here with udacity
these group presentations are really um
my favorite
part about doing this um and i think
it's because it allows us to come
together so much of the the work that
you all have done
has been kind of self-directed um and
you know this is a good opportunity for
us to come together
so that brings me to our next slide
which is to
give you all an idea of what i'm
expecting from you all
as well as what you all can expect from
me
so this really is kind of our guide to
participating in this section
so please please please if you can i
would really appreciate it if you turn
on your camera and microphone
um it's going to allow us to be more
interactive it's going to allow
us to engage a little bit better and
really just kind of
you know mimic as much as possible the
in-person experience which i don't think
that we're getting right now
um one quick thing to note that i didn't
mention here is if you're not speaking
please make sure that your microphone is
muted just so
that we don't have any kind of
interruptions throughout the
presentation
um and just make sure that the the
presentation is fitted for
for everyone so yeah if you can please
turn on your uh microphone and your
camera
don't unmute it just have it on and have
access to use it if necessary
uh one thing that i share with all
udacity students whenever i'm presenting
is if you let me i will talk for the
whole time
and i don't necessarily want to do that
i want you all to engage as well so
um if you feel like you would like to
say something or have a quick question
um you can feel free to use kind of like
the the raised hand feature or you can
just kind of speak up as long as it's
not
uh disruptive to the rest of the group
so
um yeah and then lastly um just one
thing to note is that you know in a lot
of these presentations i know that
english might not be all of your
first or primary language that's okay um
one thing that i really express
to to my students and the coaching
students that i work with is that
you shouldn't see that as a language
barrier even though you might feel that
way what it really is is a bilingual
advantage and so that's one thing just
to take note of as you're progressing
through your career path
is that this is something for you to
really leverage um the fact that you can
speak multiple languages is a huge
highlight to really be able to showcase
uh through your job search process
um and then another thing is i have a
tendency to speak fast
if you can't already tell so if i'm
going a little bit too fast
just type in a quick message and ask me
if i could slow down a little bit i'm
perfectly
comfortable doing that as long as you
all are getting what you want
out of this presentation so yeah once
again uh please turn on your camera
if you can a large part of this
presentation is going to be um an
interactive portion
where you all will be you know hopefully
kind of
engaging with each other and so that's
best done through your microphone
um or your camera either or both if
possible
so yeah without um further ado let's get
into today's agenda
so so some of you all got
the notification um well you got the
the description of the event and
one of the things that i asked you to do
was take a look at a previous webinar
if you have great you're kind of ahead
of the game
if not that's perfectly okay i would
highly encourage that you check that out
to kind of complement this session so
if you did not watch it if you can go to
udacity's youtube page and actually
go to the career webinars playlist
you'll be able to find that one so that
one is the
linkedin guide to landing interviews
without applying part one
linkedin profile optimization and then
the next thing that we'll talk about is
the importance of networking for a job
search
so those of you who may have been kind
of going
about this process we're going to try to
make sure that you have a solid
understanding of what is working what
isn't working and how to proceed moving
forward
and then we'll talk about best practices
for networking i know
most of you know this is something that
i should be doing but don't necessarily
know
how to do it um or might just be trying
to reach out to recruiters on linkedin
and that's not working either
so we'll talk about things that are
actually working for people and how
people are really getting hired these
days
and then we're going to do some breakout
rooms for some speed networking so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to
share a best practice or a tip or
something to kind of think about as
you're going through the networking
process
and i want you all to practice that with
each other so that you have a realistic
um idea of what that might look like
when you do that
outside of this specific um
space here and just to let you all know
like this is going to be a great place
to practice
nobody in here necessarily is is going
to be judging you
or your answers and so this is the place
to practice this is the place to
ask questions this is the place to kind
of really work that those nerves out
so that you can hit the ground running
when you have real conversations
um yeah yeah go ahead
uh how do you do networking in the age
of covid
and uh where you can't physically meet
people
yeah great question so you're jumping a
little bit ahead
um but great question definitely
something that we'll talk about um so
yeah thanks for for leading us into that
um but yeah we'll get into
those topics specifically this was
created with covet in mind it wasn't
something that i put together before
this has a lot of those aspects kind of
brought into it so i'll make sure to
touch on that question but
great question i'm sure a lot of other
people were wondering as well um
i would say social media nowadays
especially in covet will play a
very important role in networking
yeah absolutely social media can be a
really really great tool
um if used correctly and um
linkedin is going to be the primary
social media tool that i talk about
today
and that's kind of going to lead us into
our first kind of conversation so um
what i want to know is
uh yeah go ahead uh so can i ask
well well you are presenting if that's
okay
so yeah i just want to make sure that
the questions are relevant to what we're
talking about
kind of right now and not necessarily
jumping ahead or
individual questions that might be
specific to you
if you have those kinds of questions
let's save them till the end
but if they're related to the slide that
we're talking about p
please feel free to um ask those
questions
yes uh i have a question related to the
slide that uh first like that
i have to see yeah the linkedin
profile optimization as you have told
that
uh we we can watch the video
uh you know later but um if if if that's
okay
can you give you know a refresher maybe
a five minutes uh so that you know we
can
be get the spa base up and you know
uh go from there if that's okay sure
have we been okay with this
yeah so i mean basically it's gonna be
difficult to kind of cover that all
within
five minutes but i'll do my best to give
kind of an overview before
but this kind of jumps into this
question so um
really that webinar is designed to help
you
understand how to best position yourself
on linkedin
so that you are going into each
individual section and making sure that
you are showcasing
the keywords that employers are looking
for as well as putting forth a very
consistent brand of what it is that
you're looking for
so for a lot of people they'll have
their linkedin profile and it'll say
data science software engineering
artificial intelligence graphic design
web design in it
it can be very difficult to
figure out like what is it that you're
really good at and so
that webinar teaches you to kind of keep
that focus and make sure that the
keywords are included in there so that
when recruiters are looking for
something like data scientist
if that's what you want people to find
you for you're including that
in there so that webinar goes section by
section and we'll kind of give you a
good idea of that
once i get some time during the breakout
sessions i'll go and find that actual
link
um or if anybody else i know there's
quite a few people in here if anybody
wants to do that that would be great
um it's on the udacity youtube page
under the
videos there's a playlist for career
webinars and if somebody could find that
just drop that link in the chat that
would be great
um or oh yeah thank you so much for
for putting that in there so if you
haven't watched it just yet i would just
say click on it and kind of put it to
the side for now
because you can still fully participate
in this session if you didn't attend
that event
but now i want to know from you all if
you did watch it
if you did kind of go through and view
that webinar what are some of your
thoughts or questions that you might
have had from that
so i have a question uh i watched it
like
after completing my nano degree because
there was
that also asked me to watch it so what
if you want to like if you're looking
for jobs in different fields like i'm
looking for biomechanics as well as like
robotics and
things like that like if it's a diverse
set of fields that you can
be fine to work with so how do you focus
your profile in that case because you
say like you should focus in one part
yeah so i think if it's difficult to
focus from
keywords then i think your about section
is a really great place to showcase some
of that focus
whereas you know some things that are
related to what you're looking for
aren't necessarily the same things that
employers are going to be searching for
so you want to start thinking about your
linkedin profile
almost as if it's like your main hiring
page
and you're selling yourself or you're
selling a product
to uh you know employers and those are
kind of your
customers right so when you think about
that you have to have an understanding
of what is it that they're looking for
what is it that they're searching for
and more often than not those are going
to be job titles or they're going to be
specific skill sets
um they're not oftentimes going as
in-depth as
like python or specific programming
language they're more so looking for
software engineering or front-end web
development
or data scientist data analysts and so
those are the types of things that you
want to make sure that you're focused on
showcasing
thank you yeah uh what other thoughts or
questions do you all have if you don't
feel comfortable sharing out loud feel
free to drop that in the in the chat
as well
i have a question my name is supriya
sure go ahead
i'm noticing that i'm seeing less people
visiting my linkedin profile i'm using
linkedin premium services and
we generally get insights as to how many
people visited your profile right
and i'm seeing that number is going down
uh
what can i do to improve that viewership
yeah great question so i think the first
thing that you want to do
as i mentioned before is focus on making
sure that those keywords
are are there and making sure that
they're spread throughout
kind of the majority of your profile
especially your headline
your about section your experience
section your education and your skills
those are kind of the main sections
where you want to make sure that those
keywords are present
that's how most people are getting
traffic to their page but if you wanted
to take that a step further
what you want to do is focus on
engagement
and content creation so that's kind of
like the next step and when i talk to
people about linkedin i say that there
are really three main areas
one is your profile which is where most
people kind of
do it and then leave it um and then
there's engagement
which is you interacting with your
timeline so people who are posting
content
people who are writing articles and you
going in liking it
leaving engaging comments and not just
things like nice and thanks
and awesome you're actually contributing
to conversations
and then there's the aspect of content
creation which takes it a little bit
further
where you're actually writing articles
or creating posts related to the work
and the expertise that you're trying to
build
those are things that are going to draw
more and more and more passive traffic
to your profile
so that you could potentially even start
getting some opportunities
that you never really even applied for
so people are reaching out to you and
that's actually how i got
this role with udacity they saw the work
that i was doing and reached out so
there's a lot of things that you can do
outside of just your profile and the
keywords to bring more
traffic to your page um yeah i hope that
answers your question
yeah thank you yeah i also have a
follow-up question if that's okay
if yeah go ahead so
i typically have a lot of project work
for each of the roles that i have held
so
like there's a lot of different kind of
work that i have done
so if i decide when i look at my look
name profile
everything has a c-more section to it
right okay because there's a lot of
things that i covered in there
how ha i mean typically how much does a
how much time does a recruiter spend on
a linkedin profile and in order to
uh get that recruiters uh attention how
many lines or how much pic
should that uh you know per job summary
be
yeah that's that's a great question and
i think that you know it it's hard to
answer some of these questions because a
lot of them
um certain things like including
keywords and creating content and
engagement like that's best practice
those are things that can be kind of
universally accepted
as it relates to how much to share and
what to share
a lot of that comes down to a matter of
personal preference and
what works for you so
you want to try to focus a little bit
primarily on like what is most important
so put yourself in the mind of the
recruiter and ask yourself
what are they looking for and then that
can help you to kind of take away from
things that
might be on there that aren't
necessarily related to what you're
looking for
but yeah great questions i do want to
move on um
as i mentioned before if if you still
have questions i'm sure that that other
webinar will answer a lot of them and
for those of you who are interested in
taking that a step further there's a
part two
that focuses on the engagement and
content creation piece as well
so there's a lot of content that we
already have on demand that you can take
a look at
but let's get back to kind of the the
focus of this session thank you all for
for sharing that that's going to be a
really good um starting point for you
um and then just one thing to know if
you could i'd like for you all to avoid
putting your linkedin profiles in the
chat um for those of you who don't it's
okay
not a big deal but i don't want to get
um the messages and the questions mixed
up between people sharing their profiles
there will be plenty of time for you to
do that um towards the end
um yeah and thank you laura for sharing
the the second webinar that's going to
be um
kind of the part two to the the first
one that we talked about today
okay so now let's talk about networking
and why this is so important because
what i'm seeing
is that most people are only focused on
applying for jobs online it's the only
strategy that they're implementing
and they wonder why they're not hearing
back they wonder why they're not getting
responses from employers
one of the main things to know is that
most jobs are never even posted online
so a lot of these jobs are being filled
through networking and relationships as
well as
internal career fairs different things
like that that are outside of this
application process
the reason for that is because i want
you all to think about this from a
business perspective
um if you're working as a recruiter
right if you're working as a recruiter
and you have 250 applications for a
software engineering role
how are you going to even decide between
that large amount of people
because there's no barrier to entry in
terms of
when you can apply what time you can
apply
where you can apply from what your
background is and so they're getting so
many different resumes
that oftentimes are not related or not
competitive for those roles
so a lot of companies are shifting away
from posting their jobs online
because that they know that there are
other stronger ways to find candidates
and save the company time and money
so one thing to note is that a lot of
these companies
have um involved what are called
applicant tracking systems so these are
software platforms that companies are
using
as a way to filter out applications so
if you've been applying using the same
resume
and you're not getting any feedback
chances are this is why
because those applicant tracking systems
are oftentimes filtering out those
resumes
before a person ever even sees them and
they're doing that
through keywords something that you'll
continue to hear
through this kind of part of learning
how to effectively job search
and if your resume isn't matching the
keywords of the job description then
you're going to lose out
and oftentimes even having the best most
ats focused resume
doesn't work when they're focused on
hiring through
referrals as well as candidate sourcing
which you'll see in the third bullet
a lot of companies as i mentioned are
shifting away from the online
applications and saying
here talent acquisition team here
recruiters here's a job description for
a data analyst
instead of us posting it online and
waiting for whoever decides to apply
let's go out on linkedin and find find
me 10 people that match this description
and then reach out to them and see if
they're interested in the role so a lot
of companies are doing this
as well as referrals which and i'm
pretty sure this was a us-based study
but i think it's
fairly universal in terms of the impact
and the importance of referrals and
how you know this is the number of on
average of
how people are getting hired so on
average 40
of all people hired for a job those are
coming through referrals
so it's just something really important
to think about and if you're not doing
networking that's why we're going to
focus this session today
and giving you kind of a specific
strategy and things that you can
implement to start doing that
because a lot of people will either kind
of wait
until they need to make a job transition
or until they want to change jobs
to then start networking and so we want
to look at it completely different from
we're just doing this to get a job and
focus more so
on this idea of long-term career
success and think about it more as
maintenance then i have to cram it into
this three months that i'm trying to
make a transition you want to continue
to do these things
over time so that when you are ready to
make a transition
you already have a network to kind of
pull on so
there's so much more benefits to going
um in networking
for the long term of the entirety of
your career whereas focusing on apply
apply apply apply and cast a wide net
that provides you with no benefits
beyond that job search
and if you don't get an interview or
don't get a job offer all of that time
you spent applying online was wasted
whereas building relationships is always
an investment and a good investment of
your time
you never know where some of those
relationships will lead to
yeah uh let's see
so this might look familiar to some
people
so this is kind of what i see this is
most of the calls that i'm getting the
the career coaching calls that i'm
having with udacity students
and i'm asking them what is your job
search strategy and this is basically
what i'm getting
they're scouring job boards linkedin
indeed glassdoor
angel list wherever they're scouring
these job boards and then they're
submitting their resume
and they're just doing this over and
over and over and over and over and
they're not hearing back
usually my question is is why are you
still doing it um
and that's because if if something is
not working then we want to try
something different
and another thing to consider is that if
everybody for the most part is doing
this
how will you stand out so when you have
everybody focused on this strategy
these are the people who are oftentimes
not the ones standing out or having
success it's the people who are doing
something completely different
or doing something to be unique or to
stand out in this process
one of the best ways if not the best way
to do that is
through relationships and so
if this is what you're currently doing
that's okay this is normal
but if it's not effective i want you to
take a break from this strategy for a
while
and try something a little bit different
there's absolutely nothing stopping you
from continuing to apply for jobs online
but that's not what today's focus is on
um and if you think about it just in
terms of from a numbers game
it's an ineffective strategy not
everybody's going to get those positions
if 200 plus people are applying for them
it's going to be
one person so think about the
percentages there of of your chances
um so we want to lean away from this
strategy if this is something that
you've been doing
now you know better um and we're going
to try something
a little bit different so this is the
strategy that i
want you all to start implementing or at
least trying um because this is where
i've personally had success this is
where my students are having success and
and people that are providing career
advice it's not necessarily this model
this is something that i put together
but for the most part you'll start to
see the same things
um so the first things first is you need
to know where you're going
in order to get there and if you're just
applying
wherever you're never going to make
progress towards that
so what you need to do is really refine
and find your focus
so that's step one that's going to
determine how we put together your
resume or your cv that's going to
linkedin profile
that's going to determine the
conversations that you're having in
networking opportunities
so as i mentioned at the beginning of
the session it's important for you to
have a very clear focus
about the types of roles that you're
interested in and i know
because i'm one of those people that a
lot of people
have varied interests there are
different things that they like to do
there are different things that they're
good at but as it relates to a job
search
you are better off focusing and having
all of your materials focused on kind of
one area maybe two three i would say is
pushing it and that's max to what you're
looking for so you don't want to say
you know i'm looking for a data analyst
role but i'm also
open to a back-end developer role and i
could also do digital marketing you know
you want to be focused and if you are
going to include multiple different
things
they should be somewhat related um so
you may say you know i'm looking for
either a data analyst role
or um a data scientist role if you have
that skill set
um or you might say you know i'm either
looking for a data science role or a
machine learning engineer role
you know things that may be a little bit
more closely related it's okay to to do
that but you don't want to
go too far off because think about it if
you're in the position of hiring
are you going to hire the person who
says that you know
you have an opening for a front end
developer you're going to hire the
person who says
i am a front-end developer or are you
going to hire the person who says
i'm a front-end developer i'm a data
scientist i do this i do that i do all
these things
it kind of dilutes that specific skill
set that they're really looking for
so you want to have that focus at least
for your job search once you get that
role
you can say whatever you want because at
that point
it's it's up to you and how you choose
to brand yourself but that's really
important at least for the job search
part
because people more often than not are
looking to hire
specialists rather than generalists and
so
it's important to to keep that in mind
also where you're targeting
so if you're looking at startups they
may be a little bit more interested in
somebody with a varied skill set because
you might be required to
you know wear multiple hats or be
involved in multiple areas
versus a major company you're probably
going to be focused on
one specific task with one major project
versus doing a lot of different things
so you have to know where you're going
in order to really focus your branding
to appeal to those types of employers
um i see that there is a question
shakar yes sir uh my name is mohammed
and i am a lecturer at one of the
leading universities in pakistan and i'm
teaching engineering courses but
i have done my uh data analyst nano
degree
uh recently and i want uh transition of
the job
from one profession to another
profession so
i am really confused how to apply i mean
watch
either i should write a title that i am
i have done data analyst nano degree
is it ethical way to apply because i
haven't
done any job like that but i am applying
for the first time
so is it okay to write data analyst in
my title
yeah absolutely i think it's important
for you to do that one of the things
to keep in mind is that if you can
analyze data
you can call yourself a data analyst you
don't have to have a full-time
job title officially for you to be able
to say that about yourself you know most
entrepreneurs or people who start their
own businesses
aren't able to do that unless they claim
to be good at that so
you have to have that confidence in
yourself to be able to say
i am a data analyst in order for me to
want to hire you to be that you know so
if
if if you're lacking the confidence to
express that i'm going to lack the
confidence to hire you for that role
um there's there's nobody that's um you
know auditing linkedin profiles and
calling your employer and asking you
what you're doing obviously you don't
want to lie and you don't want to over
exaggerate but if you analyze data it's
okay to include that in your headline
that you're a data analyst
and going to your point what a lot of
people will do let's say for example
um you know you you somebody wants to be
a data scientist and they're a math
teacher what a lot of people will do is
they'll say like
math teacher aspiring to be a data
analyst and you want to flip that
to say something like data analysts with
a specialization in
math education or with a background in
math education or something like that so
you're putting forth what you want
that's the only way to start getting
attention for the things that you want
us to start putting it out there and
claiming that for yourself
yeah um in shakar you had a question i
think
so my question was like so about finding
my focus like this should the focus be
according to what you're interested in
or what you
like what do you think that your
previous experience would entail if you
don't have a job right now and you want
to find a
new job after graduation yeah absolutely
you can't just put something out there
and expect that people are going to hire
you
that you know putting that out there and
listing that in like your headline or in
your
about section that's just to get the
attention but once they're there
if you can't sell yourself in your
experiences then you're not going to get
hired anyways
so it has to be a good mix of both you
have to
target things that you're qualified for
as
those have to kind of overlap what you
want and what you're qualified for
those have to go together frequently if
you want employers to take you seriously
so the idea of putting it out there is
really more so to draw attention
and then hopefully your experiences is
what really brings it home and sells it
to the employer that's getting to your
page
so a follow-up question would be like if
i
i'm i'm a mechanical engineer like i did
masters in mechanical engineering and
then i also
i also did a nanodegree on ai
programming with python
so i i don't have like ai experience
other than that degree so is that like
good enough experience to say that i
want to go in that direction or not
why do i need to get more projects and
like before that like how do how do i
decide how
do i know that the experience that i
have is
enough or not yeah that's a great
question and
it's very common that i'm getting these
these questions from
students so it's a great question i
would say the best bet for you
is to start looking at job descriptions
online
and kind of measure up your experiences
to that so if you're looking
at those positions are you even
qualified for
because what a lot of people do is they
go into this process and say
you know they only think can i convince
them that i can do this job they forget
about the part of being competitive as
well
and they're really those both sides you
can't just say you know i'm qualified
for this role i deserve it
if you're going up against 100 people
who have the same qualifications
if not more then you're you're not
giving yourself the best chance possible
that's where this strategy that you know
we're presenting on today
it really comes into effect because
realistically there are plenty of people
with master's degrees
that are still out there job searching
and then you add
another layer of difficulty with the
pandemic and how that's affected the job
market how that's affected business
and so you know it's like how you're
you're counting kind of the things
against
you so trying to be competitive with
just a piece of paper
is going to be very very difficult um
and so that's why you want to focus on
the relationship building piece so that
you stand out from your relationships um
because your qualifications may be kind
of average
um or even slightly above average most
of the time people are going to hire
people based on the trust that they have
that they can come in and really hit the
ground running which is important these
days
because so much of our work is online uh
but yeah i want to make sure that we can
continue to keep going um if you still
have questions let's save them towards
the end
um but yeah i'll try to make sure that
i'm answering questions as we go
uh let's see uh will this job stretch
will this work for internships as well
yes absolutely
um internships very similar you still
want to be doing this especially as
as a college student you should be doing
this
throughout the time period that you're
in college so that when it is a time to
apply for those internships
you're really focused on building
relationships with people at those
companies
that's what's going to put you over give
you the edge over everyone else
so after you kind of refine that focus
you want to put together a list of
target companies
and there's so many different things to
think about here so
oftentimes you know and this is just a
little bit of tough love for you all
often times most of the udacity students
i'm talking about i'm talking to they
want to work for amazon they want to
work for google
apple netflix facebook all great
companies
however if you are not the top
technical talent in the world it's going
to be very difficult for you to land
jobs at these companies you're not just
competing with the people in the bay
area
you're not just competing with the
people in the us you're competing with
people across the world
and so you have to be self-aware enough
and realistic enough to
say do i even compete for these types of
roles
i know i can do it but can i compete for
a software engineering role where
they're hiring people who have already
been doing this work for three four
five years and it's okay if you don't
feel confident at that point yet
there are more than just 10 companies in
the world and
just because those are the most
successful companies in the world does
not mean those are the best places to
work
so it's okay for you to take a job at a
company that you've never heard of or
that you've recently discovered
because once you get that experience it
puts you in a place to be
more competitive for some of those
better known
higher paying you know what i call
sexier companies
so take your time you know be realistic
and work your way up
so many of the students that i talk to
want to skip all of these steps
and jump directly from college to like
data science
data scientist role or jump directly
from you know a nano degree to a
engineer role and while you might have
the knowledge or the skill set you lack
the experience
so be realistic and think in mind you
know
what what can i qualify for but also
what can i be competitive for
and so if a lot of you are starting out
or don't have a lot of experience to
back it up
you want to focus on probably some of
those smaller safer companies
especially now when we're dealing with
the pandemic and competition
is kind of through the roof for a lot of
the competitive roles
so just be realistic and and know that
you have an entire career ahead of you
there's no rush for you to jump into the
top companies
at the highest level that you can get to
there there's no rush let's take our
time let's look at it as stepping stones
and pieces to eventually get there
uh let's see um i see people talking
about um adding actively seeking
opportunities or open to work
um so there's a lot of different there's
a lot of different
opinions out there about that um you
know some people will say
yes it lets people know that you're
looking some people will say if they
know that you're open to work
they that seems a little bit desperate
it shows that you're not in demand from
other employers
so i can't i can't give you an answer
because i don't think that there's a
right one
i think you know a lot of this has to do
with you know taking the advice that i'm
giving you taking the advice that you're
reading
and making a critic a critical you know
do some critical thinking and make the
best decision that's right for you
because that isn't necessarily there's
no right or wrong answer as it relates
to that
i haven't seen any studies or research
that has shown one way or another
um but based on what i've seen i think
you know
just do what's most comfortable for you
um okay there are a lot of questions
coming in i want to make sure that the
questions
are related to what we're talking about
so we don't get too too far off topic
um so yeah let's continue to go through
this strategy because i think this is
really one of the most important parts
for us to get through today
so you have your focus in terms of the
types of roles that you're looking for
you're creating a list of companies that
you can use
to kind of start putting together like
this is where i'm going to focus my
networking efforts
at that point now you have the end in
mind you can see the mountaintop you can
see the finish line
now we know where we're going versus
just kind of going
aimlessly and not really knowing we have
kind of an end in mind that we can work
towards
so very very important that you put
together that that list of companies
um one thing that i will make sure that
i include once i get a second is i'm
going to go back and find the template
for the company list that i put together
for udacity students you can use that to
put together your list
as well as use it as a networking
database
so you can kind of keep track of the
conversations and the relationships that
you're building with people
so that's just the first step and so
in between kind of this first step and
the second step
right in here you want to make sure that
your
application materials are together so
you want to make sure that your linkedin
profile i would say is probably more
important than your resume or your cv
just because you can get passive traffic
there and you're getting more views
there than you would get on your resume
or your cv
but take a look at that webinar the one
we were first talking about at today's
session somebody dropped it in the chat
i'll try to make sure that this is
included in the replay as well
but you want to make sure that your
linkedin profile
is branded well that there are keywords
throughout
and that it shows consistency
so that employers can find you and
potentially even reach out to you versus
you always having to be on the the more
desperate end of the job search
so you want to make sure that those are
together because once you start having
conversations
you might have someone ask you for that
that you might have someone asked
ask for your resume or your cv and you
want to be ready to present that to them
so once you have kind of that target
list of companies
and you've improved your linkedin
profile at that point
then you can start reaching out to
people at those companies
on linkedin and what a lot of people do
is a lot of people will only reach out
to recruiters
or they'll only reach out to hr managers
and that goes back into that same
strategy
as before i'm sorry uh
this is this is what most people are
doing
so if most people are doing it most
people are not gonna have success doing
it
so if we go back to this point and if
everybody's reaching out to recruiters
which most people
are their inboxes are going to be
flooded with messages
and so you're not going to be able to
stand out unless you put something crazy
in that message
or your cv or your resume is just that
much better than everyone else's
and so you want to focus on people who
are actually within your network
reaching out to recruiters and
networking are not the same thing
what i want you to start doing is
connecting with people who are
in the roles that you are interested in
or in
similar related roles because those
people are going to have
more of a connection with you than the
people who are
in recruiting roles if you're talking to
a recruiter they're not going to be able
to discuss the ins and outs
of digital marketing often times they're
not going to be able to discuss the ins
and outs of autonomous systems and so
you want to connect with professionals
who are in those spaces
on a regular basis because they can give
you advice on how they got their job
they may be able to connect you with
other people who are doing similar work
and it might just be nice to have people
within your network who do the same
thing
you never know where these relationships
may lead they may lead to
you two starting a business together
down the road it may
simply lead to you two hosting an event
together um and those are common things
that i've done
as a way to network as well so it's
really about
every time i tell people about reaching
out to people on linkedin i say ask
yourself this
really important question could i see
myself
building a professional relationship
with this person
even if it never leads to a job at this
company and
the reason why that's important is
because it allows you to approach
that conversation and that relationship
from a much more genuine perspective
it allows you to approach it from a
place of i'm trying to build this so
that it's good for both of us
whereas if you're only reaching out
basically asking somebody to give you a
job
at their company on the receiving end it
it doesn't get me excited to want to
help you
you know a stranger reaching out to me
asking for a referral or a stranger
reaching out to me
you know asking me for something that
they need it doesn't
you know i don't have the time or the
capacity to help every single person who
does that especially if i'm working at a
top company
so focusing on the people who are doing
the work is is important
in approaching it from a genuine
perspective so that even if it doesn't
lead to a job at that company
it could lead to a referral two three
four years from now
it could lead to you giving them a
referral down the line and so
you want to look at it a little bit
different um than
just kind of i'm reaching out to you so
you can help me it's very selfish
it's you know very one-sided and that's
oftentimes why people don't respond to
messages is because they don't feel like
they're getting anything in return
so it's really important that you have
that together
and that you're doing that as you're
thinking of reaching out and then
having that first initial connection is
great but then we move down to this idea
of relationship building
and it's not just about having one
conversation with them oftentimes
sometimes it's more
about you know checking in every other
month on that person asking them how
that big project is going
and and focusing on doing that with your
list of target companies
so that when we get to that point where
positions are available
you can kind of reach out to that person
and ask and say hey i saw that you all
just posted
you know a junior devops role would you
mind
submitting a referral for me at that
time you've taken time to have
conversations you've taken a little bit
of time to build that relationship
and that's where you have that ease of
asking for referrals
and so i know that this might seem like
a lot i know that this might seem
intimidating
some of the companies on my target list
you know even when i'm not job searching
i'm still reaching out and trying to
build connections
those haven't provided me with any jobs
in the last two years
but there have been some that have
happened within less than a month so
the strategy i wouldn't necessarily
change because it just depends on timing
and it depends on the level of trust
that you're able to build with those
people
so when you're thinking about who to
reach out to and who to connect with
you want to make sure that you have
things in common with that person
so that it's easier for you to build
that relationship
okay let's see i see that there are
some questions one person asks is
is this the right time to change the job
in this current pandemic situation
that's a great question i personally
this is a personal opinion
i would say no but we also don't know
how long this is going to last
so i think if you're in the space where
you have a job that
you're okay with i would say focus on
your skill development focus on building
your network focus on connecting with
people at companies that you're
interested in
so then again when positions become
available you can reach out
but it's just it's a really really tough
job market right now and so i think
trying to aggressively job search or
leaving a job that you have to try to
find something new
it's very very very risky and and i'm
personally not
not that risky um especially during a
pandemic to try to do that
so yeah i see a couple of these
questions are very individual i want to
make sure that we have
some time to get through this so um i
hope that this is starting to make sense
in terms of being proactive and doing
this throughout your career so that
you're not just doing it when it's time
to job search
because if you go that route of applying
online you're going to be frustrated
it's going to feel like you're running
in place and not really making any
progress
whereas with this every virtual
networking event you attend as a win
every meeting that you have is a win
every new connection that you make is a
win
and that's important for you to think
about i had one other question
just coming back to that original
question other than linkedin profiles
what other ways are there for networking
yeah great question um we're going to
get into that um so we'll talk
specifically about some general
platforms to use um but those two are
linkedin is really kind of the primary
one but we'll talk about another one as
well so yeah
hopefully hopefully this is starting to
make sense for everyone
but this is kind of the strategy that
we're going to go through today
so i want to hear this is sorry
uh one quick question since we are on
the strategy slide
uh this will be very specific like what
are your thoughts on
when you want to switch between the
industry like i will be very specific
like from consulting to tech industry
now you don't have the experience you
might have a skill set but you don't
have experience how do you
attract employers there and
relationships build relationships there
yeah great question i'll answer that and
then and then let's move on um
so for me you have to get the experience
there's
oftentimes not you can't skip that step
and so if you're trying to get into that
space
you know networking is huge because
those are the people that are going to
give you the opportunities
but you also can't go through your
career expecting that people are going
to give you chances every time you need
one
so if you want to make that transition
look for the skills and the experiences
that are necessary
and then find ways to gain those
experiences it may not be through an
official employer it may be through
volunteering
it may be through hackathons or projects
it may be through passion projects
non-profits volunteering with
entrepreneurs or small businesses
there are so many different ways to gain
that experience whereas i see a lot of
people are just waiting for someone to
give it to them
and they'll end up waiting for a very
very long time but then also
a lot of those opportunities that you're
able to get to gain experience are
coming through people that you know
so it is it's kind of a shift in mindset
the way that we're approaching these
things we can't be passive
we can't wait for people to give us
opportunities we have to go out there
and find them create them for ourselves
so that when it is time to be
competitive we can talk about those
experiences
because even if you get a referral once
you get to that interview process
and you say you know i don't have any
experience to talk about they're gonna
you know oftentimes give you the boot
and find the person who's done it before
so you have to have that combination of
the skill set and the knowledge
the experience to back it up through
examples and stories and then the
networking just to get your foot in the
door
so all of these things are important if
you want to kind of progress throughout
your career and those are the people
that i'm seeing have the most success
so just a little addition to what you
respond
um there is a website it is recognized
globally
it's called a sec a e i s e c
dot okay so this website provides global
connections
uh via volunteership and internships
and many people especially living in the
third world countries
have found good employment opportunities
using that
especially internship opportunities for
uh graduates
so okay if you allow me can i drop the
link
yeah i was gonna i was gonna ask you to
if you could please uh put that link in
the chat so that people can kind of pull
that up for them
for future use yeah i really appreciate
you sharing that
thank you so much yeah okay so
let's talk a little bit more about
linkedin outreach and then i know
somebody had a question about things
outside of linkedin
uh we're gonna get to that as well so um
as i mentioned
when it comes to outreach uh one of the
things is you want to kind of connect
with the people
at your list of companies doing this
proactively right
because if you're trying to reach out
and build a connection just because you
want a job
those are going to be more difficult so
do this before jobs are even open do
this before jobs are even available
if you know that there's a certain
company that's doing cool things or
doing things that you're passionate
about or interested in
those can be really um great
opportunities for you to then connect
with those people so that when a
position does become available you can
pull on that
relationship um another thing to do and
this step two is one that people often
miss out on
so when you look at someone's linkedin
profile oftentimes
between the about section and the
experience section there will be a
section for activity
if they've been active on linkedin which
means that they like posts they've
commented on posts
they've shared posts or they've written
their own articles or anything like that
and the reason why this is important to
check is because if they don't have that
section there
chances are they're not active which
means they haven't liked commented
engaged on anything
or their activity may say that they like
to post three months ago
those may not be the best people for you
to reach out to because
chances are they might not even be
active users of linkedin they may not
see your message for another two three
months
so focus on reaching out to those people
who may have commented or liked or
shared you know
within a week or two those are people
who are
going to be more likely to see your
message more quickly those are also
people who have kind of bought into the
idea of linkedin
and and what linkedin is used for so
those people are going to be more likely
to respond to your messages
another thing to do for step three is
take an interest in their work or find
something in common
so review their profile in depth maybe
you went to the same university
maybe you both completed nanodegree
programs maybe you volunteer for the
same causes
read their about section maybe they play
video games and you play video games
that's something that you can
you know talk about or if they're more
of an industry leader
you can kind of read one of their
articles and use that as a way to
introduce the conversation so type in
you know
hey i read your article on how data
scientists are helping improve the
progress of covid
hear my thoughts or you know ask a
question those are great ways to show
that you've invested time
in and and you um you appreciate their
time
and you appreciate their work it's a
great way to start a conversation
um and so a lot of times when it comes
to linkedin outreach
it's not about asking for something
right away it's about
building kind of a bond and building
some trust so that when you do make that
ask whether it's for a referral
or simply for a video chat you know a
15-minute phone call
those become a lot easier because they
know that you're genuinely interested in
getting to know them and not just
looking for them to help you
and then you know as i mentioned try to
make that connection
and then here are some things to keep in
mind as well that a lot of people think
i'm doing this wrong or i'm not doing
something right you
will get ignored know that going into
this that people will ignore your
message people will not respond to your
message and that is okay
um they may not see it they may have
seen it and been extremely busy
um they may have seen it and you were
asking for something and they weren't
able to help you i've been in each one
of those three bubbles before and so
i you know can't say that i've responded
to every single message that i've ever
gotten
but you know i have usually you do
usually respond to the ones where people
are reaching out from a more genuine
place
or i just have the time to help them at
the time so
know that you will get get ignored do
not internalize that do not say they're
not responding because
i'm bad or because i'm unqualified or
because my profile stinks
know that it's just part of the process
so it's okay for you to follow up
and be persistent with them so maybe if
you reach out and they don't respond
sending them a follow-up message maybe a
week later and saying hey
i just wanted to to follow up and ask
and if at that point they're not
responding
i think it's okay for you to move on um
so there's no right answer
there's no right time frame it's just
you know kind of use your best judgment
use your common sense
and if people are ignoring you um change
your approach
try something different but really i
think you're going to be most likely to
to have success with
with approaching it from a more genuine
adding to perspective response um in
microsoft a scholarship at udacity
um i have made an air table i mean my
group has made an
a table in which we are collecting
linkedin links and get updates of
those scholars and students and
especially everyone who are interested
in making connections with each other so
i have
maintained that table in which there are
many scholars who have
added their linkedin links and
especially if
this group is also looking to
add their linkedin links or connect with
them they are more than welcome
okay can i share the link yeah please do
please do share that link
for anybody who's interested in taking
advantage of that no i really appreciate
every everybody who's
sharing resources and things because one
thing to keep in mind
is from us on the careers team most of
us have backgrounds in leadership
corporate leadership hr education you
know recruiting we're not technical
experts and so we're not
frequently you know in all of these
spaces and so
you know i want you all to take
advantage of you know each other in you
know the best
way possible you know i want you all to
share resources a lot of times
you know when we're going through the
job search process like oh i found this
opportunity that's perfect for me let me
apply and not
share it with anybody else you're not
going to have a lot of success
throughout your career if you kind of
keep everything to yourself because at
the end of the day
it's not something that you created
knowledge is not something to be owned
in my opinion that's why i love the work
that i do anytime i learn something new
that helps job seekers i share it
because i know that you know the more
i'm recognized as a helper
the more people want to help me back and
so
if you have resources please share those
in student hub please share those in
slack please
send those to each other you guys have
to do this together
often times this is you know a resource
for you all to work together
partner on competitions partner on open
source projects those are ways for you
to gain experience without waiting for
an employer to do it for you
um so yes you know definitely um
use each other as resources and help
each other
brett can i ask a question please just
just
one thing and if if any one of you
are also interested in letting others to
make connections with you
uh everyone is allowed to edit the a
table and
add your linkedin link into it too
okay great yeah no that's helpful
thank you and who had a uh yeah sorry
yeah brett and i got a question about
step four
okay go ahead when you're making a
connection you've got the opportunity to
add a note to that connection haven't
you no two yeah connection
is that good etiquette because you've
been doing a lot of like
um make a connection and just say expect
people to reply go who the hell are you
and they've replied saying yeah great
because i used to work with them that's
what i've been doing before
but now it's like right why am i
connecting with you so
would you would you recommend that then
add in a note to each connection you
make
yeah no i think i think that's best
practice i think sometimes even i don't
do that
um just because you know sometimes i
just want to connect with someone to see
their content
and i think that's something that i need
to work on is just making that clear you
know adding a note and when i say
connection here i don't necessarily mean
like that actual button
i mean like something that you all have
in common um but yeah when you're making
that connection request
if you add a note um you know usually
when i'm more serious about it i will
include something if it's like okay this
person
um i saw them create a post that i liked
i might just
you know send the connection request if
i'm not if i don't have the time to just
sit there and draft a message and say
something but yeah
i would say if if you really want to
start
creating more genuine relationships on
linkedin adding that note is a great
place to start
whereas a lot of people will use that
note to say things like
well they'll make a request or ask
something and i don't think that that's
best practice to ask for things from
that first message but yeah
um i think that's a great question i
would continue to do that if you are
um oftentimes that is helpful to then
pull something from their profile or
pull
from something that they posted so that
you're not just adding them randomly
because there are a lot of people on
linkedin who will just add ad ad just to
increase their follower count
and you know you don't want to be seen
as that type of person
i have a question i'm really sorry to
serve you again
um sir does endorsement really helps in
i mean getting uh concreteness in your
profile yes so the endorsements help
but you're better off having skills that
are related to what you want
i would just once again encourage you if
you have any specific questions related
to the linkedin profile
just refer back to that webinar just
because we we have some other things to
get through and i really i don't want to
discourage people from asking
those related questions but a lot of
that is covered in that content
um so i would just refer back to that
the endorsements are helpful but you're
better off having a related skill with
no endorsements
than an unrelated skill with 99 plus um
so make sure that those skills are in
alignment with the keywords that you're
showcasing and the things that you think
employers might be searching for but
yeah
still it's still a great question yeah
okay so let's talk about some things
outside of linkedin and and once again
just a reminder please try to keep
questions related to what we're talking
about
um we have a lot of people in in the
webinar today and i want to make sure
that we're able to get through the
content as well as get a chance to
practice
some of these skills so meetup is an
amazing resource
this website is helpful and i know that
there are
meetups groups across the world may be
more popular
in you know bigger cities or more
well-known places there may also be
other websites that do something similar
but meetup is a great website for you to
find
specific groups of people so it's not
just professional related it's not just
career related
but it's becoming one of the most you
know
you know helpful networking platforms
out there
so there are meetup groups that you know
people are involved in that relate to
fitness
they're ones that relate to you know
reading or business but there are also
ones that are specifically related to
career groups
so spend some time looking through that
when you have some free time check out
that website download the app and just
browse through there
you'll see these group names but
basically meetup was designed to
help people to gather around a certain
topic so
not necessarily professional or social
but it can be anything
obviously meetup is designed for people
to meet up in person and we're dealing
with a global pandemic that isn't
allowing us to do much of that these
days
however there are some things that you
can take advantage of
these days because of meetup so
my first tip for this is to find more
specific groups
so you know find things that are more
closely related to
who you are as a person so as i
mentioned in this example
you know if you're a woman and you're
working in the data science field you're
better off
going in that group than more of the
like broad it professionals group
because that first group is going to
give you a group of people who have
similar life experiences
people who have similar career interests
and those are going to
be it's going to be much easier for you
to build a bond and build a trust there
to where they're willing to submit
referrals so
um there's a group that i'm involved
with um
that i don't think it was through meetup
but i think they might have one
there's one and i'm in atlanta georgia
in the us it's called technologists of
color
so it's a broader it group but it's for
people who
identify as like a person of color or
just want to be involved in that group
to learn from them
and so that combines kind of technology
but also a little bit of culture
and so you know look for those groups
because those groups are going to
help you find more like-minded people
with similar experiences
i see that somebody posted facebook
groups as well those can be helpful too
so finding people who are within the
same industry this is
what networking is networking is not
meeting people so they can get you a job
networking is not reaching out to a
recruiter so they can get you job
networking is connecting with people
like you
and people who are kind of in similar
industry for collaborative
mutually beneficial relationships when
you start to see networking as more of
that
it becomes much easier there's not
necessarily a huge
skill set that you learn to develop and
just get good at it it's more so
shifting away from
i'm doing this to get a job to i'm doing
this to get to know people
and build relationships and collaborate
and work together
and add value that's where you'll start
to see more success
and then another so tip two this is
actually a benefit of covid
i didn't think that there were any but
um this can be helpful because you can
join meetup groups in locations
where you aren't physically there now
because where most of those meetups took
place in person
now a lot of them are transitioning
their programming and their events to be
virtual
so if you really want to move from
where you are to let's just say
barcelona
you could check to see what meetup
groups they have out there
and then you can start engaging with
people who actually live there
who work for companies there who could
submit referrals for
you there so you'll start to see kind of
how this process
works and that's a huge advantage to
going more virtual is that
now if you really want to move somewhere
you can start engaging with people in
that area already
speed networking events panels webinars
like this
um probably more technical if you're
looking into those meetup groups
but um that can be a big advantage and
then another thing
lastly is that some of these meetup
groups take it a step further
it's harder to find some of these the
bigger ones tend to have more
involvement
but the the the groups oftentimes will
have like a private slack channel
or a private place to communicate where
you can have more passive engagement
so i have gotten referrals in the past
from people that i'm just in the same
slack channel with
and that's because that slack channel
was people in
education technology so it wasn't just a
broad it group it was a smaller group of
people in ed tech
so combining education and technology
they're just wanting to help other
people in that same space and that was
like i got that referral within like
a couple of days of having a
conversation with that person
so know that this is not you know going
to take you years all the time it's not
going to take you five six months
sometimes it can happen very quickly
but those opportunities are more likely
to happen when you're in groups that
are more that you can relate to because
you're meeting more like-minded
people you have more things in common
you have that trust kind of already
established
that's how networking truly works and
that's how you're going to start seeing
more opportunities become available
for interviews so linkedin and meetup i
think are kind of the gold standard
right now for networking in general
but you all might know of some more
specific
tech related uh meetup groups and then
they're obviously going to be
tech groups related to specific cultural
groups whether it be women minorities
there's a really great group called out
in tech that that helps
provide resources for people who
identify as lgbtq plus
there are a ton of groups out there
obviously you know i don't have access
to every single one of them
so it's important for you to also be
able to do your own research and and
find those for yourself
so yeah okay that was most of the
content for today so
let's talk about some actual strategies
and things that
i've worked um really well with in terms
of networking because
you know once you're able to kind of get
that person's attention once you're in
front of them now it's like
well what do i talk about um or or how
do i interact with them or what
what do i say so now let's let's take a
look
um at some specific strategies and
specific things that i've used that work
really well
that you all can start practicing with
each other so
this is how we're gonna do this so i
think there are four different tips that
i'm sharing so i'll share that tip for
how to have conversations then i'm gonna
split you into breakup rooms i'll
probably do
maybe because there's so many people i
would say probably groups of
four um just because some people might
not have their microphone on some people
might be observing
ideally it would be two people but
that's only if every single person on
here participates
so i'll put you in about groups of four
then you'll practice doing the specific
tip that i share and then um we'll go
back into the next one and we'll kind of
repeat this process
um but if if
do we have any questions about this
before we get started
no okay cool so let's go ahead and
jump right in so this is kind of my
my best practice part one so i think
a lot of times people struggle with
networking because
they you know pre-covered they would
attend an event
and it's just like oh yeah nice weather
out here today and
how's your day it was good so i want you
to
ditch the small talk for the sake of
small talk so i want you to
speak more in depth i want you to share
things about yourself i want you to be
vulnerable
obviously within your comfort level so
i'll give you an example
so anytime i have an interview or any
time i'm in a networking environment and
somebody asks me about my day
i try my best not to just say good and
keep it moving
if they ask me about my day i'll say you
know today started really great
um i was able to go grocery shopping i
meal prepped for the week
i'm you know ready to to be productive
this week i was
or i was able to go for a walk this
morning or i was able to work out this
morning or you know what i mean like so
i want you to to speak about yourself
give people things to talk about
because if you say something that they
can relate to that's how you start to
build those connections that's how you
start to build that bond
um you could talk about recent successes
um i'm personally in the process of
trying to buy my first home so that
is something that a lot of people might
have in common um
yeah just some things like that you
could even talk about netflix shows it
does not have to always be
so professional you don't always have to
talk about
tech sometimes it's just about getting
to know a person so
now i'm going to break you all out
into rooms i have a question
okay yeah go ahead now what about
elevator speech
i mean uh can we prepare an elevator
speech
just uh for introducing ourselves
i mean in order to start talking i mean
like many people
go towards weather talking when they are
really into expanding the
amount of talk so
how do you suggest we all should prepare
our elevator speeches
yeah so we actually have on that
webinars playlist um i didn't facilitate
it but i know angela did
it was a session on putting together an
elevator speech which i think is great
i want you all to focus on being people
today
and not being tech robot professionals i
want you to just have conversations
that's really what networking is all
about obviously having a good network
a good elevator speech is helpful it's
necessary it's good for you to have
there's a resource there that you can
check out for that
today i want you to talk about you i
want you to build connections i want you
to get
in common practice of just talking to
people like people
because those are going to be the
relationships that you build trust with
those are going to be the ones that
serve as referrals and connections for
you down the road
um thank you so much
did some did someone have a question
uh give me one second i'm having some
issues with the breakout rooms
uh okay well this is part
of being an online educator is
troubleshooting and improving on the
spot
so we're gonna scratch the uh
we're gonna scratch the breakout rooms
but i'm gonna have you all
volunteer um so i have a couple of
people
volunteer to uh do this really quickly
and we'll use you all as our guinea pigs
um
so is anybody interested in volunteering
anybody want to if you're interested
drop it in the chat i'm interested
uh somebody said the attendance is
dropping like stock market
once they were asked to talk to others
um it happens frequently
um not a problem some people don't have
microphones and cameras it's okay some
people just don't want to do it
both are perfectly fine okay so let me
see
i will have okay let's see i haven't
heard from
taylor taylor bacchus or bacchus and
then
let's do
just picking these people randomly i
promise
cameron comrade k-a-m-r-a-n
so kamran and taylor bacchus
hi my name is taylor backus
nice to meet you um so i just recently
completed the
production let's go okay
all right it's cool hi nice to meet you
um
i just recently completed a product
manager nanodegree
i'm i have been a project manager for a
long time working with creative teams
and i'm looking to have better
bridge the gap between the two teams
when i'm working with creative and the
product team
um and you know since completing that
i've kind of been enjoying my summer
really
embracing the opportunity to start
cooking more things that i haven't had
the time to
do before and then also looking into
various types of courses in addition to
udacity
some language courses so that i can kind
of broaden my cultural horizons and be
able to communicate with more
people and then even looking into things
like grammar classes
yeah that's great yes that's great um
i'm network engineer
and currently i pass you know cloud
develops number three degree we'll move
on to the cloud
since my last experience is a little bit
similar to my
future you know and transitioning
position
and i'm working but sometimes jumping
the cars you know i'm trying to
make connections on linkedin more and
reaching out to recruiters uh and
if i have time i'm watching lucifer on
netflix
i like that you know seriously that's it
uh what's that one about
yeah i said this real
movie like you know uh dramatics
comic comedies you know this kind of
thing it's very nice
okay so it's not it it's
yeah it is five serious and uh
the the supposed to be to stop you know
produce industrials but netflix
you know about that the original that
fundament and the
you know trying to make it you know
producing that one
oh okay i'll look into it that sounds
awesome um i've been watching
dark which is a german show on netflix
which is
very dark so far but interesting yeah
nice so are you working now currently or
yeah i'm not currently working so i'm
looking for new roles um i lost my job
during covid
and i'm kind of just working on
expanding my skill set while i'm looking
for new
great good luck thank you
so yes okay so great very very good i
i just i want everybody to get in this
kind of concept of like
networking does not have to be stuffy it
does not have to be
super overly professional and it does
not have to be just to get a job
um it can just be conversations um
okay let's move on to the next one
so um now i want you
to find well and i'll give two different
two other different people
so um i want the next two people to find
something personal not professional that
they have in common
so i'm gonna pull from the people
i'm gonna the first two people i saw are
julian gomez and kyle law
so if you guys can jump on i want you to
as quickly as possible
find something personal that you all
have in common
uh kylo here hi
julian can you hear me yes i can
okay
so that's kind of awkward
okay of course next time for me my
hobbies are basically
playing chess i i playing chess this
this morning and every day every morning
i regard just paychecks to
refresh my mind and i recently find a
pretty great
learning chess website just for anyone
if you are interested in
learning chess it's called i pretty much
enjoyed
a lot of it so yeah this has been much
about my hobbies
how about you julian great that's
interesting i
haven't played cheers in a while but uh
i guess i will give it a try sometime
maybe if you maybe
uh share that website with me okay uh
however
of mine well pretty much i would say um
i would say i uh i read a lot of books
uh
like especially at night right now i'm
reading
this one in
the grand biography yeah
okay it sounds interesting
about it's about the
general uh general ulysses grant is
experimenting reconciling experiences
specifically during the civil war and
and then once he becomes president right
now i'm still in the middle when he
fastens the civil war
so and uh i know how it is that uh uh
i will watch the dollar netflix uh well
well besides
uh taking the time to to learn from
udacity
yeah same here i enjoy reading books and
learning from udacity as well
yep yeah
cool all right let's do two different
people
same topic uh let's see i'm gonna have
laura and shariff
hey laura
i didn't volunteer
you i i thought you did it's okay
okay well i'm volunteering you that's
that's that's the teacher in me
[Laughter]
um go ahead you go first i i i'll let
you start
yeah no no you start
uh so recently i quit my job
for my highest studies so past month
all i've been doing is learning how to
cook so
uh today i learned a new recipe called
khichdi i don't know if you've heard of
it it's an indian recipe
it came out well what's in it
it's just rice and pulses
so came out well so pretty happy about
that
and also indulging myself in so i'm from
uh
data science background worked in it for
three years so
i'm just shifting myself and focusing on
web development so that
as an hobby i'm learning so that i can
build my own portfolio online
yeah i'm in web development too but
we're not going to talk about that
because we're supposed to talk about
person
web development as a hobby the non-work
hobby yeah
yeah what about you i enjoy cooking too
i've been experimenting with uh
pork roasts and uh i've found that brown
beer
and granny smith apples in a pork roast
very very nice cool maybe you can send
me the recipe i'll try it out
okay y'all have to open
one up very very good very good and i
see that some people are like actively
networking in the chat as well
so if you if there's anything that
people are mentioning feel free to jump
on okay so now i want to do this again
um but i want one person to to come on
and talk
and then i want anybody who can relate
to jump on the call
because this is like virtual networking
this is how it works okay maria
volunteers
uh maria i want you to just start
talking about some of your
passions or your hobbies or your um
quarantine activities and if anybody can
relate
um i want you to jump on hi
thanks for giving me the chance to talk
i volunteered twice actually
sure um so when
the parenting started i thought this is
a great opportunity for me to
get some of my flexibility in check and
get more exercise
since i wasn't commuting anymore i had
more time
and i really like yoga i'm really into
yoga
and i thought i'll have time to do
splits now i can learn to
the only thing is i'm also quite
ambitious so i
i kind of injured myself um
so it's not a great thing to be stuck in
the home without uh
being able to see a medical professional
for a few months
uh but i guess that teaches us a lesson
right so
don't push too hard whatever you're
doing
um even if it's a hobby
uh it's you know take it easy that's
what i learned
um and yeah so i really like um
yoga and i like dancing
moving as much as possible we're all
technologists here
so sitting in front of the computer for
a long time i think you can all relate
means maybe moving is not
part of your daily routine so much so
i'm
personally trying to incorporate that as
much as possible
when i have a free free moment yeah
i can i i'll jump in um so
i have so i go through my phases of
exercise and working out and i stopped
when covet hit because i stopped going
to the gym and i lost like 12 pounds
just from stopping to work out and i
know like for some people that's
ideal but for me i got skinnier than i
wanted to be and so i've been working
out again
lately and i think there's just i don't
like to do it
but i like the fact of already being
done with it for the day
it makes me feel good about doing
something especially
in the middle of covid where most of us
are just sitting in the house doing
nothing all day so i've been going for a
lot of long walks around my neighborhood
as well
i completely relate to that and i think
everyone
i've spoken to that are even like really
into sports and a bit obsessive about
sports
they say they don't like it it's just
the after effect the endorphins at the
end that they enjoy
maria do you have a favorite course that
you're doing for yoga
or an instructor that you follow yeah um
i really like
kinder mcgregor from home stars and i
um i bought a yearly membership
do you know her no she's from
florida um a really well-known
yoga teacher in the us and she has a
website called omstars
and it's really good for beginners too
she has
multiple levels but if you've never done
yoga she goes through
all the details step by step and i'm now
doing a
journey to handstand so
let's hope i'm not falling can i jump
into
yeah go ahead um well uh
not related to yoga but uh when kobe
uh there was a boom of online courses
i took learning as my hobby as my hobby
not as a professional thing
because i am already doing two masters
so
making uh you know side learning
uh a part of your profession will be
very hectic
so i try to consider learning as
my hobbies so i just i mean blindly took
i mean courses and courses and courses
and then
i was like i mean you can say i was
getting exhausted from
so many courses that i took so one
advice from my
site after this forward 19 experience
that i mean if you get any opportunity
don't just jump in try
to sit down and think for a moment that
whether
this activity that i'm going i'm going
to do
is really worth my time in because uh
you know the best thing quarantine has
offered us is
time i mean free time many of us are
having
so much free time so it's very crucial
for us to
dedicate time aside to
think about and reflect on ourselves
that what do we want and
how are we going to achieve it
personally speaking uh
before covert 19 i used to get
so i used to be so much busy that i
never have a time to really sit down
and think for myself that what i want
from myself and what i want for my
future
so i would highly recommend all of you
to
set aside i mean a small amount of time
like half an hour or an hour
and try to envision your future that
okay now i have time let's decide what
we truly want from ourselves so that was
good
yeah thank you for sharing that message
i think all of us could
use a good reminder to focus on
ourselves and taking care of ourselves
okay so this is how i want to do the
next one so now i want you to talk about
something professional
um so i want let's see i think
mario are you still in here mario
maybe hopefully uh
let's see
um onshul onshul come on come on come on
the the uh
come on down you're the next contestant
um okay so i want what i want you to do
is just talk about
um i want you to talk about your
nanodegree program um
and i want anybody who has taken or is
currently taking the same nanodegree
program to jump in and just
i just want to hear you all chat about
that program
sure bro and thanks for choosing me now
hello everyone
i hope everyone is doing good um quick
background
so i started as a computer science
engineer then i moved to us and then
i moved into consulting because it
sounded exciting
and now i'm trying to move back to the
tech industry that's where
udacity came in because in tech in
consulting it's
mostly you know reaching out to people
networking that
what we are trying to do here and then
you know doing those small talks
starting a conversation and then letting
them
understand that how valuable we are and
then they will pay you
for the project that they want from you
so that's what i've been doing but then
now i'm trying to shift to
tech industry from consulting and
started doing udacity courses so i
started with
data analyst nanodegree from udacity
then i recently did a
sql nano degree that i completed i'm
looking forward to
a product manager nano degree that they
have recently
uh listed in udacity so
uh that's that's next on my list because
i'm targeting
roles like product manager or data
science role something related to data
and metrics and on a daily level that
you interact with data that because
that's what i'm doing also in the health
care
health care right now and for my
on my skills and expertise uh as i said
i was a computer science engineer before
this
then i moved into uh consulting but i'm
still
uh working on data related stuff so
daily interaction with healthcare data i
was working on some of the projects
which are related to covet 19 right now
so helping some of the big farmers and
then
well my career goal moving forward from
here is
land into a tech industry uh some big
like those fan firm and then
probably own up a product start some do
some strategy for that product and
be a product owner or a data scientist
moving five way down down the lane so
that's
that's my career goal hopefully i'll be
able to achieve that
with this whole thing going on and i
attended this event just to
make sure what i'm doing right now to
connect with different people
in those target firm whether my
strategies are correct or not and if i
can if i'm able to improve the strategy
so that that was one of my goals from
this workshop
or from this webinar first of all
awesome and second thing is uh
which nano degree related to product are
you interested in
i mean there are mainly three nano
degrees that are offered
uh first one is product nano degree
product management and other
second one is data product manager and
the third one is growth marketing
product manager so among these three of
uh which one are you really interested
in
i think the recent one that they have
introduced the data product management
because that calls out to my
experience and skill sets more and
as i see with with some of my friends
working in the tech industry
i see that they are more focused towards
data and then when you work on data
um you can get a lot more insights
and then you know you're better able to
answer
things to both your customer and to the
leadership that you're interacting with
so that's why i think data
product manager degree is more relevant
for me
very cool for your nano degree thank you
hey ancho this is supriya here i too
just go
i'm good how are you doing doing good
coping up with this california fire
right now it's all over all
ash and brown sky right oh my
god yeah we experienced that i am up in
portland oregon and we had a
wildfire a few years ago and
though i am miles away from that
wildfire i could
have layers of ash and you know all over
my car so yeah cleaning that up is going
to be a mess for you
yeah anyways my car is all like a dump
right now i've not been outside a house
for like almost three or four months
so yeah yeah that's the story with
everyone so i forgot
yeah so uh i i mean um my
i took up the digital marketing
nanodegree i am a marketing analytics
professional
and i was always uh
you know my trolls were pro limited to
email marketing and
so i wanted to expand my horizon and see
what was digital marketing i mean
whenever i would look up and
read online there was limited resources
and the best part about udacity
nanodegree is what i felt is the ability
to have hands-on xp
exercises and try it out and it really
helped me
you know gather those skill sets and
hone my
skill sets as to improve as to where do
i want to go
though i'm not working right now but i
can it kind of help me as to which
direction i want to head to
so i wanted to ask you i mean why you've
taken up so many
uh udacity degrees like two or three of
them how are you utilizing all that
information knowledge in your current uh
profile
um i would be able to better answer you
probably in two three months
but thing is it's a good way to start
initiate
you know where you want to head to and
it gives you
if you don't have understanding if you
don't have a baseline it gives you a
base to start thinking from there and
yeah i think where i'm struggling right
now is as i asked the question before
is the experience so i do those uh you
know capstone projects industry
industry level projects and then i
prepare i
make up my profile but the thing is uh
i mean now there are so many people
doing those udacity projects that
as brett said you have to stand out
right so
even though doing those udacity project
you have the skill sets
standing out is a little difficult now
so
what i'm thinking now is whatever i've
learned and trying to apply those
maybe on some kaggle projects doing
something on my own so i have a
i do a lot of gaming so i play league of
legends online
and then you know counter strike so
those are my past time on weekends
because you can't go outside so i happen
to get access to the data
so league of legends right games they
have an api you can download data from
there
so i recently got access to it and then
i explored that option and then
i'm trying to do some analysis on top of
it because it's a domain
which i'm very interested in so that
will help me with that data science two
main expert
experience and then trying to build up a
project on that
just to show in my github profile that
okay i have
learned from udacity now i'm applying
those skills on a
interesting project that i'm doing on
all by myself there's no
mentorship or mentor or teacher who's
guiding you there
probably that will help me stand up yeah
i wanted to
i wanted to jump in on sure because i
think you
shared a really good example of you know
being able to gain that experience and
really develop your skill set
um and that's something that i usually
encourage to a lot of a lot of my
students is find ways to involve your
passions like the fact that you're
bringing that
into like your passion for you know
gaming and esports like that could
potentially put you in a position to
where
you start reaching out to people at
esports companies or gaming companies
you know
you know these these places that are
there putting together these games in a
booming industry start building
connections there start having
conversations about the projects that
you're working on related to
running that data and making use of it
and showcasing to them your value
that may be an opportunity for you to
really stand out
and have conversations where you're
combining multiple interests of yours
so it may not happen as quickly and i
don't know where
you know a lot of times people get this
idea that people are transitioning
careers within a couple of months
i think a lot of it has to do with like
the marketing
but realistically when you look at these
nanodegree programs i
usually encourage my students like i
want you to focus more so
on the skill development and putting
together quality projects because
at that point like the certificate
itself is
still very new udacity is still a
growing company a nanodegree is still
you know becoming known as what it
stands for so you need to focus on being
able to
get that confidence and if that means
that you can use that to
pull in data from league of legends or
counter-strike i think that that's so
cool
and for me i'm i'm a gamer too so that's
how
you start to build those connections and
then now because i know that from you i
know potentially like if you and i were
to have more follow-up conversations if
i'm ever
introduced to someone in the esports or
the gaming industry and they're looking
for someone with your skill set
i have you top of mind so this is where
the networking comes in and becomes very
impactful and very relevant
is when you're able to not only you know
get those experiences on your own to me
that showcases a level of autonomy and a
level of like being able to self-start
that i want to recommend you i you know
and
because i'm a gamer i think that i
connect a little bit more than people
who don't
so you know it's it's important to have
these conversations about the projects
that you're working on because that's
where you might start to see some value
and i think
like you said udacity is still a growing
company
when we showcase our uh nano degrees
from audacity
how do you think we should show it of
like
can we circle our profile around it or
should
that uh nano degree just be a part of it
how do you how do you expect that that's
a really great good question
and that's a really important thing to
consider because
when you because some people sometimes
they'll put on their resume or their cv
or their linkedin profile they'll just
say
um data analyst nanodegree to someone
who doesn't know what udacity is or
doesn't know what a nanodegree is
that could mean an hour that could mean
a two hour course a two week course a
three day course
you're not providing the context to show
that off so
what i encourage people to do is really
focus on selling it
you know not just me being a udacity
employee but you all have to be udacity
ambassadors in a sense
because you have to be able to sell that
experience because for someone who
doesn't know about
it they're you're making the assumption
that they're going to go on
udacity's website go to that nanodegree
program review the syllabus they're not
going to do all of that
the recruiters are going through
hundreds of applicants so you have to
tell the story that you want them to
hear
and so talk about you know provide that
context
talk about how long it takes to complete
whether that's in hours
weeks months whatever talk about the
overarching modules that'll help you
infuse more keywords into your profile
but also talk about the major concepts
of that
um nanodegree program so you know a
master's in computer science everybody
kind of knows in a sense what that does
um or a bachelor's degree that's more of
a universal concept
a nanodegree or a boot camp or things
like that you know
there's so many people that are popping
up with these different programs
so that's another reason why i mentioned
you know focus on the skill development
focus on the projects don't rush to get
their certificate
because at the end of the day you still
have to be able to sell that experience
until there becomes some universal
standard or some accreditation for these
online certificates or the brand just
gets that reputable
you have to be able to showcase that so
i think writing a description on your
education section of your linkedin
profile
and even including links to your
projects you can start using your
linkedin profile as if it's a portfolio
include the links to your projects
include the links to your github repos
include the links to your digital
marketing portfolios all of these
different things that you're putting
together
sell it showcase it because to the
average person they're not going to know
what that means
sir i have a question uh in the linkedin
in linkedin there is a certificate
section
and we cannot provide uh details of the
nanodegree program that what right that
what are the projects we have done so
far
right so what is the right way to
showcase that what projects you have
done
uh either in the about section or
whatever you suggest
yeah so i would suggest if if for those
of you who haven't
um once again referring back to that
first linkedin webinar
that'll be helpful but just to answer
your question if you're going to
showcase that
i say put it in your education because
that allows you to write a description
that allows you to upload media
whereas in the accomplishments or the
certifications licenses area it doesn't
allow you to do so
so i would say put your nano degree in
your education
write the description and upload media
or include links to your projects that
you've completed
also this one what you could do is you
can write a post about your project
and provide a link about the link of
github
and then people would like it and share
it so you
you reach further so that writing a post
about it is also a good idea
yeah great great great comment and so
just lastly we don't have to necessarily
go through an example i know we're like
way over time but um you know this is
this is this is the event for the day so
um
you know and a lot of people have done
this throughout the presentation right
but
this is probably the best thing that you
can do the kind of one of the big
takeaways from networking is always
always always try to add value and this
is something that i
say when you're posting on linkedin as
well like just
being known as a helper being known as
somebody who provides resources who
shares things
it makes people want to help you and so
some people shared
yoga courses some people shared netflix
recommendations as i mentioned in the
pro tip
it doesn't have to be just professional
it doesn't have to just be focused on
nanodegree courses or you know me
providing you with a service or me being
able to do something for you
sometimes it's just about building that
connection and finding that
being known as somebody who helps and a
lot of times
when i was you know pre-coveted and i
was really aggressively networking
i would offer to buy people lunch or
offer to buy them coffee and sometimes
just the offer itself was enough to get
a meeting
sometimes they declined it and just said
you know i can do 2pm on thursday we
don't have to meet for lunch
um and so just showcasing to them that
you value their time
that you're willing to make it a
mutually beneficial relationship
that's the most important part of this
all because as i'm sure
some of you can kind of attest to like
just some of the conversations that
you've had here
you have things in common outside of
this you're all going through this
experience together of
covid or you're all going through this
experience of being a udacity student
and so
you guys i'm assuming are going to be a
little bit more likely to want to help
other udacity students
so it just kind of puts into kind of
kind of context some of the things that
we've been talking about today and how
finding those connections and being able
to to connect with each other
is what's most important like the your
entire career is going to revolve around
relationships because that's what the
world revolves around if you're ever
interested in building a business
if you're ever interested in dating it's
all about building relationships it's
all
you know people focus you know you could
be the most technical
expert in the world but if people don't
like you it's going to be hard to
to want to hire those types of people so
that's kind of like the the overall
takeaway is just to try to always add
value
and make sure that when you're leaving
those conversations
you've made it clear that you want this
to be mutually beneficial you're not
just trying to get a referral from them
and i think that that
hopefully is the biggest takeaway from
um this session
so now i just want to know if you do
have some specific
some specific questions um i'm here
these can be individualized they can be
general
as i mentioned um i'll probably hop off
here in like 15 minutes there's there's
no rush
um so yeah does anybody have any overall
questions or anything that they're
hoping to get okay let's
let's uh let's do this um i'll have you
all
raise your hand if you have a question
just because i know that there's still
some
i have a question uh can you please give
me a career guidance that
i i have done my bachelor's in
engineering
and then i have done my master's in
electronic engineering and then i came
to know that
okay i want to jump into data science
career
and i have just started my nanodegree
programs
in udacity and i want job in this
in this area for example for instance if
i don't get a job should i
should i go for a phd in this period uh
what you recommend
great question so i'm this is a very
common question that i get from a lot of
udacity students and oftentimes it's
the question basically getting down to
like generally is like if i can't get a
job should i go back to school
whether it's for a master's degree or
phd
there you know the good thing about
going back to school is it puts you in a
place where you have a lot more
resources you have access to a career
services department you have access to
faculty you have access to events
you have access to internships a little
bit easier than you would outside of
that
however what i see oftentimes is people
get their bachelor's degree and they
can't get a job so they go back for
their master's degree
now they have a master's degree and
can't get hired because they have no
experience
so going back to kind of that previous
point that i made you
have to kind of you have to hit all of
these areas you have to have the
knowledge and the skill set
and the expertise you have to have the
experience you have to be able to
showcase to employers how you've applied
what you've learned
the same thing same reason why a
university graduate
is going to have a hard time getting a
job without internships or part-time
work or student involvement
and then you need that networking to
help you get that foot in the door help
you get that chance to show off your
skills
so i hate to recommend people saying you
know go back and get your phd or go back
and get your master's degree
when you're going to end up in the same
situation where you still need to have
that applied experience
a phd is a little bit different
obviously it's higher level
but you know there's still that
possibility that you graduate with that
and they're still
trying to find how you've applied what
you've done to real-world situations
um so and then sean says having done a
phd it's not always the right thing it
doesn't guarantee you a job it's a much
bigger commitment than a master's
part of the reason why i never went back
for mine um but
just to you know kind of go back to your
question like you know
it's not going to be guaranteed so don't
get a phd just
to increase your chances of getting a
job i would say go get a phd if you're
extremely passionate about this work
maybe if you want to teach at the higher
education level
maybe if you want to do research or
become a leading expert
but if it's just to increase your
chances of getting a job i would i
wouldn't recommend it
um because then you have to think about
the financial aspects to it as well
and brad if i may add just one
additional point to it
based on my experience in the last six
months of searching a data science job
sure uh what i've seen is they really
value
this would be really specific to all the
data analysts or data science job
related things so they really value your
github profile how you are building your
projects
and then you're listing it on the
linkedin back to linkedin so
udacity projects are very good for
initial purposes like
starting off but then how you're
applying it and then building your
github profile
and showing that again back in your
linkedin profile and in your resume like
a link
is really helpful and i've seen that
with my phone of two of my friends who
have landed a job in google
as data scientists two years back that
they had links
in their resume to their to their
projects and they have built their
projects
slowly over time and yeah that's
what they help them get a call from
those
from those company as a data science
data scientist so that's really helped
them and that's what i'm trying to do
now
so yep that's my two cents there
hi angel i have a question for you
so on the point that you said that we
should have a github profile
maintain data profile so i think that's
not specifically for data science but
instead for all data scientists jobs
that we are looking for currently in the
market
uh keeping on that note actually
i just wanted to ask you
i am working as a data scientist
full-time so i don't get much time
uh to like build my get up profile have
some personal projects
even if i do have time i would like make
a project
up in three or four months a viable
project
so uh that would not like count up as a
github profile
even if i work for like an ear so how
can we like
go for that i'm sorry brad
just addressed to me so it's fine if i
answer that no go ahead yeah i'm
answering a question in the chat so go
ahead
okay so kanika i believe right yeah
so uh so the point that i recommended
was people who don't have
experience in data science so they want
to show so if they're learning
they're learning and they want to show
their experience to build up their
twitter profile
with you i think the advantage is that
you are working in data science
so you can readily show that experience
in your resume and in your linkedin with
all those projects listed so even if you
are not able to i believe
if you're working professionally on a
project you may not show them
on on your github with the codes and
everything
um shown to the public so but you can
list those projects in linkedin and your
resume because you're professionally
working so you can definitely show your
experience there
which i think count as equally or
above the gita profile when you're doing
your personal projects so i think you
have an advantage with your experience
as a data scientist
work rather than you know personal
projects being listed on github
i have a question from you that uh
as you have mentioned that you are
working on data science
carrier is it necessary to have
to have some skills on developing site
like html css javascript django
framework
should i also learn these things or why
should i skip
these things and just focus on data
science
feel free to pitch in but based on my
six months last six months experience
i'm not working on those html and css
i'm just working
on the specific data science project and
in the
interesting domains that i can find
projects on
so i think they are more uh
they want more in data science they want
your understanding
of the maps working behind the code so
do you need to understand the map that
is working on that in the algorithm
and then how you're applying that math
uh correctly and choosing the algorithm
correctly to
get on a get the insights from a
particular data set so that's what
really matters if you have
html and css that's like a cherry on top
but i don't think that's required but
yeah
html css and javascript is like a
complete package
you can build your own end-to-end
application if you have those skill sets
yeah no i think that's important to
mention too because
you know there and just being realistic
about the career services here with
udacity there's only so much that we can
help you all with
because we're not technical experts so i
can't answer the same questions that you
all can oftentimes answer for yourselves
i wish
i wish i had the the the skill set i i
am a nanodegree dropout so i couldn't
even finish the intro to programming so
kudos to you all for for
for keeping that up um but just know i
have a question
for you relevant to you
so um i have a three years experience in
uh data science field
i've quit my jobs to pursue my highest
studies i'll be going to france in about
20 days
okay so i have a year's time so how do
you um
expect me to spend this time like uh in
networking and
building links so i have the years time
for my academics now
okay i i didn't i didn't hear your
question can you just repeat the
question so i i said i i
just quit my job uh recently uh to
pursue my higher education
which is a one year program uh msc in uh
international business so i'm going for
that uh
now so how do you expect me to spend
this one year in
in terms of networking and other stuff
yeah no i think that's a really good
question and i think anytime you can go
into a situation like that
thinking proactively you're putting
yourself in a better position
because oftentimes what i see with
people whether it's you know pursuing
higher education or not
they wait until like the february or
march before their graduation in may to
start
applying for jobs and doing job search
related activities
so as you're going through the the
program meet with all of your professors
connect with the faculty members in the
in the department
ask for referrals to people in the
industry do do that strategy in that
wheel to where you have a target list of
companies
so that when you graduate in may or
december or august whenever you're
finishing
you've already built some of those
relationships so that when it comes time
for you to actually find a job
you're only focused on referrals and not
submitting as many cvs as you possibly
can so do that proactively
get your company list together as soon
as possible so you can start making
those connections because think about it
like this
if if you work for let's say you work
for abc company and i really want to
work there
if i reach out to you and say hey sharif
i saw that you all just posted a
position
i'd love to chat about your experience
that seems
you know very genuine and that's an okay
approach some people might be open to it
versus me just reaching out to try to
get to know you and then i ask you a
year from then
you know it's a different dynamic so you
approach the relationship building
proactively to where you're not asking
them for anything but you continue to
follow up you continue to check on them
you continue to you know have
conversations hopefully the relationship
builds that way so that when it does
come time for that referral it's it's a
it's
obvious yeah i'll help you yeah i'll
send you the referral yes i'll do that
um so spend that time doing that take
advantage of all the resources for any
of you who are
in school my background is in higher
education i worked for a university for
several years several different
universities and one of the biggest
things i can say is that students
do not get their money's worth they
complain and complain and complain about
how much it costs
but they don't go to the career services
office they don't go to career fairs
they don't meet with their professors
they don't attend events they don't go
to their counseling sessions
they don't seek tutoring so take
advantage of it while it's there people
are genuinely there
and want to help you and those are the
students that i see have the most
success people with multiple job offers
once it's time to graduate
uh yes priyanka listen
so i wanted to ask what to avoid putting
in a linkedin profile so that we
don't kind of repel the job providers
um it cut out just a little bit i wasn't
able to hear if you could just try to
speak a little bit louder and a little
bit slower hopefully i'll be able to get
your question
okay what should we avoid
putting in our linkedin profiles so that
we don't
avoid uh don't repel the job providers
gotcha so what to avoid um
i would say one of the biggest things
that i see people do is they complain
on linkedin they use that as a place to
vent about their job search frustrations
and nobody wants to hire that type of
person obviously you know we all have
complaints about the job search process
about hiring
a lot of times i'll see people just bash
recruiters or talk about
how messed up the system is that doesn't
make people want to hire you
i would say other things to avoid it's
it's hard to say there's not
a whole lot that i would say to avoid
just i would say use your common sense i
think it's more so approaching this from
a place of like
what should i do versus what should i
not do
um in that that one webinar that um i
was referencing throughout the the
presentation i think that that's
probably one of the better ones that
i've done with udacity
and one that i reference all the time so
i would just refer to that
don't go too far beyond kind of the
recommendations and the best practices
if you want to get creative
by all means go for it but in general i
think best practice
know what the employers want you can
learn that from the job description you
can learn that from conversations with
people at that company
and just appeal to those needs the same
way that businesses do
you know when you look at a mcdonald's
commercial right
or or any type of food right anytime
they have a commercial on tv
they don't brag about how well their
business is doing they appeal to your
needs
they show juicy dripping food and
you know delicious looking plates
they're appealing to your needs
so you have to start seeing these
employers as your customers
know what they want based on job
descriptions conversations research
on articles new projects that companies
are working on
and then appeal to that through your own
experience
that's kind of my best recommendation i
hope that answers your question
yeah it does thank you yeah no problem
okay
so we're about out of time i know we sat
here for two hours didn't really feel
like that hopefully we can have some
more
um just general conversations i don't
want us to always have
to talk about um strategy and career
advice sometimes it's helpful for us to
just connect and that was really my big
takeaway with this event was for
everyone to stop seeing networking as
like this means to an end something i
have to do to get a job it's more so
building genuine connections with people
building that trust so that when it does
come time for a referral
it's easy to ask for that but then also
you should be trying your best to
create mutually beneficial relationships
with
the people that you're you're seeking
help from um
i know obviously i would love to live in
a world where
everybody wanted to help without getting
anything in return um
but we we don't and sometimes we just
don't have the time to to help for free
or
help you know especially if we have
multiple people pulling from us so
just try to make um try to make your
relationships
mutually beneficial try to reciprocate
try to add
value um and i truly believe if you
follow kind of that outline you have a
target of where you're going you build
genuine relationships with those people
i really truly believe that you'll start
seeing more success in your job searches
versus applying for jobs online um so
yes
thank you thank you thank you so oh yeah
go ahead one last question
uh is it a good practice to ask for the
endorsement on some skill set
from others i would say yes but don't
ask strangers it's kind of weird
um you know if you if they don't know
your work
it's weird for you to say can you enjoy
endorse my work for this
um so reach out to previous classmates
colleagues
i mean you could post it in udacity if
you have people who are doing the same
nanodegree program
that can kind of help them justify doing
it for you
but i wouldn't just reach out and and
ask randomly i think that that's
kind of strange but yeah great question
so um thank you all
so so much for joining i really really
appreciate it if you
are interested please feel free to
connect with me on linkedin
um as i mentioned i try my best to make
sure that i'm having genuine
conversations with people so
um forgive me if it takes longer than
normal to respond
but yeah please connect with me connect
with each other and i know you all have
access to
everybody has access to the alumni slack
channel right can i get a thumbs up
okay um good so take advantage of that
you know
that you know slack channels and
different things have been some of the
most
relevant and helpful resources for me
and my job searches
so it doesn't just have to be you know
these live events where you're
connecting with each other
start conversations spark them up you
don't have to wait for
our team to post a question to start
engaging
he said share the slack channel i would
so i'm going to
give you an email because i don't have
access to that
so if you have any questions at all
regarding
kind of the career services um this is a
great email to
to use career dash support udacity.com
um you can ask them for uh access to
that slack channel if you don't already
have it but take advantage
of that participate in the office hours
create topics for each other private
message each other
connect on linkedin all these things
you guys want to help each other out as
much as possible
so yeah thank you all age i just got the
pop-up for the breakout rooms
um but yes thank you all so so much for
attending i really appreciate the
the engaging um style i really
appreciate you all sharing and
volunteering and
and thank you all so much if you have
any further questions i dropped the
email there again it's
career support udacity.com and hopefully
we continue doing uh similar events to
this so
um once again thank you all for
attending i hope you have a great rest
of your
morning day evening whatever that looks
like for you we'll talk soon
thanks bert thanks for going over time
thank you